um so our first talk will be by rachel
tapman
um rachel is a developer advocate for
rasa where she helps developers
build and deploy conversational ai
applications
um rachel has a phd in linguistics from
the university of washington
washington where she researched um in
computational sociolinguistics and she
was also a data scientist at kaggle
where she's still a grand master today
so
rachel do you want to get started
yeah let me just uh
share my slides when you're ready yes
i'll stop sharing
fantastic
nope that one all right
we go all right move everybody over here
so i can actually zoom uh
yes hello i am going to talk about rules
and deep learning
um and why we use both of them
at raza and before i do that i think it
might be helpful to just
like quickly uh elaborate a bit on the
the wonderful introduction that arthur
gave me
um so i'm actually from virginia so
y'all like the woods uh i got my
my baa in english literature and
linguistics at william and mary
and then i moved out to seattle where i
currently am at the university of
washington not the one in st
louis different one um and i got a phd
in linguistics and computational
sociolinguistics was
my my main focus um looking at how
social identity interacts with the ways
that you produce
and perceive language in computational
context and using computational tools
um and i also worked in speech stuff so
phonetics from the linguistic side and
automatic speech recognition from
the signal processing side um and then
ethics and fairness accountability and
transparency in nlp we're sort of
my main focuses uh and then after that i
went to to google
kaggle um which sounds like there's a
lot of data scientists here so
some folks might be familiar with kaggle
and i'm at raza
and before we got started somebody
mentioned
it might have been jean i don't remember
i'm so sorry
um that they hadn't heard of raza before
so we are a company that makes an open
source
conversational ai framework and we'll
talk a little bit more about some of the
components while we when we go on
um and we are an infrastructure layer so
we don't do hosting we don't
um you know hold your data or own any
servers
uh we produce the tooling and sort of
the framework for
for building uh conversational ai
systems
uh and because we're an open source
company we always get the question how
do you make money
and the answer is that we have the open
source tooling
it's all in python and we also have a
free to use
but not open source tool called raza x
that
once you have a working prototype we
recommend that you use for
deploying and developing over time so we
espouse a process called conversation
driven development which is like kind of
slow human in the loop
where people talk to your assistant you
review those conversations you annotate
where they went wrong
you add them as training data or you
change the labels or you correct
things you retrain you redeploy so ci cd
but with a data annotation
and machine learning component to it
and if you are a company who is
happening to look to run around the x
server and you need lots of fancy
features like
um you know authentication flow and
having different people have different
levels of permission
and all sorts of tiny bells and whistles
uh then you pay for that and that's how
we make money so
if you are looking to build a
conversational ai and would like more
information
feel free to reach out i am uh around
the corner rctatman on twitter and i am
very available on twitter all right
brief history of nlp i should preface
this by saying i spend a lot of time
talking to developers either who are
brand new
to nlp and have more of a machine
learning background or software
engineering background but not a whole
lot of nlp background
or people in the startup space who are
uh coming up things without maybe a lot
of academic background
i know somebody mentioned uh that they
were from from ibm so some folks here
this may be review but just in case it's
not a very brief history of nlp
so nlp did not uh emerge fully formed
when neural networks did
uh it was a field and uh you know
research paradigms and
methods that existed well before that so
starting
in the 50s a lot of the earlier nlp
systems were
symbolic and rule-based and the rules
were written by linguists
by hand um and some examples of these
early systems would be for example
eliza which was uh an early chatbot that
was
a therapist and when you um said
something to eliza um that was parsed
and then
regurgitated to you as a sentence a
sentence as a question
using a bunch of you know hand built
parse trees and stuff um
and those very very early rule-based
systems
uh worked really well you've probably
used some of them um and if you've ever
done like a
uh had a an automated interaction like a
phone tree or like
press one if you're concerned it's about
automotive insurance that sort of thing
so they still exist they work really
well
um for for what they're good for they're
not super flexible
and they do require a lot of building
stuff by hand and then
in the sort of 1990s to do thousands ish
these are very approximate dates
uh statistical methods really became
into therefore uh and basically what
that just means is counting things and
then taking those counts of things
usually words um and uh making them less
sparse and then using them to do
various things um so a lot of the sort
of corpus methods
uh corpus linguistics methods are still
more based around these sort of
statistical methods
and then in the 2010s so when i was in
graduate school
um we really started to see more neural
embeddings
uh neural methods um so things like
neural embeddings which are now i think
most people would consider
sort of standard for a lot of nlp tasks
uh recurrent neural networks when i was
in grad school the hot thing was
bi-directional lstm for the attention
people still work on them they're not i
should say specifically in research
spaces they are not
the sort of the main thing that people
work on anymore and then in 2017
to sort of current day um they're sort
of another wave of the neural methods
which is
transformers specifically so
transformers if you're unfamiliar
um like recurring neural networks there
are specific family
of algorithms for doing machine learning
um
and basically instead of a recurrent
neural network you know
popping through your sequence and you
look at everything in order uh and then
you have that sort of
before i look at x i have to look have
looked at x minus one and before i look
at x minus one i need to have looked at
x minus two
you get rid of that gate like that
bottleneck by looking at everything
all the time um the downside of that is
that there are a lot more parameters you
need to learn the upside of that is b
that you can parallelize learning those
parameters so it can't be faster
so that's where we are now and a lot of
people who have um at least that i
talked to
that have come into the field uh very
recently are like oh well transformer is
the only thing that are right everybody
uses transformers for everything
um and this talk i hope to dissuade you
of that
uh belief uh and
just to be uh a little bit more explicit
about it
uh roy systems are good and they have
benefits
uh so a little bit of a comparison here
normal methods are really flexible so
the really nice thing about neural
methods
is that instead of you hand constructing
rules
you take some sample of the data and
your system learns to extrapolate
given that sample so they're very
flexible they're good at
making guesses handling things they
haven't seen before
they're probabilistic so you can do you
know rankings and have sort of a more
complete idea of what's happening
whereas with a rule you usually get like
one output or the other um and
that's fantastic and that's what makes
them really useful and that's why people
use them and that's why we use them at
raza and i'll talk
about how we use um particularly
transformer methods but also
neural methods in general um in our
framework
uh but they're not good for everything
so
um probably something that most people
are familiar with is that they
are a little bit unpredictable so for
things like text
generation you may have heard uh or seen
some of the stuff around um
recent transformer language models so
language models are
statistical models and i'll talk a
little bit more about them in particular
in the future
but um a language model was developed
with statistical models and it's a
probabilistic
model of given a token sequence and
some you know some vocabulary which
token is most likely to come next
um and then transformer language models
are sort of an extension of that
principle so given the string
what word goes next or what word goes in
the blank
so when i say they're unpredictable um
i've actually been using
uh if you all heard about this tay so
tay was a chatbot out of microsoft
that used fed user data directly back in
during training without any sort of
human annotation
and as a result really quickly after
being launched started saying some
really vile file things um
and unfortunately i now haven't even
seen full from this year
uh we're pretty much the same thing
happened unfortunately so
uh lee lula was built by a uh a korean
firm or a student at a korean firm
and they are a um like a web chat
service for people that are interested
in dating so sort of like uh
i don't know like a tindery bumble sort
of vibe
if those are things that you're familiar
with um and
pretty much as soon as it was launched
it started saying um
generating so you would talk to it and
would generate texts back at you
um hate speech specifically hate speech
towards the lgbt community and then more
people did more probing and it turned
out that you could get like
people's personal information from the
training data that they shared
during their you know discussions with
other people on the dating app
um and it was a whole big mess
um and part of the reason is because
things are done probabilistically
and usually with some degree of sort of
like
you know sprinkling of of additional
improbable
not improbability um with some
additional fudging
i guess um you you don't know what's
going to come out all the time
and that makes them problematic
particularly in a chatbot sense
the other thing is that they require a
lot of training data
and transformers in particular i
mentioned that they have
more parameters than recurrent neural
networks and the more parameters you
have the more data you need to train
those
parameters the more space and time and
compute it takes
the more expensive it is um but the data
is a real real bottleneck so
raza is language agnostic we support a
lot of
we use python uh in our in our coding
uh human language agnostic so
the assumption that you're going to have
a lot of training data available for any
particular
um uh assistant
is um really english-y
so here i have a paper from some of our
community members who are working
in vietnamese they published this last
year and they were looking at several
different
potential ways of taking words in and
turning them into numbers
and the the tensorflow sort of training
from start to finish yourself with your
own training data
um and then the fast text which were
pre-trained using fast text which is
just a type of embedding
um did much better which much less data
than ember which is multilingual bert
which requires
a lot more data for fine-tuning because
to simplify it because it's bigger um
and they just
did not have the data for their
assistant
or available in their language so
uh and the the additional
points about transformer language models
specifically
um is that they're really big um so this
is
a um non-linguistic so i guess i could
have made it logarithmic but i didn't
um chart where uh the uh
language models are sorted by time and
as you can see over time
they have gotten much much larger this
is number of uh parameters in millions
um and gbt3 is no longer the long
largest transformer language model
there's been one
out of google i want to say that there's
one been out of
um 10 cent i keep saying that and i keep
remembering having read it and i can
never find the citation when i look for
it but
um these are getting bigger and bigger
and bigger and because they're bigger
they need
a lot more data and they need a lot more
compute and that
it's just expensive like i i think the
estimation is that gbt3 took like 12
million dollars to train just in compute
uh which is certainly not in my my
budget and as a result in order to use
them you're probably going to have to
use somebody's api
uh microsoft has the api for gpt3
and then the thing that keeps me up at
night
is uh you can get the training data out
of
um these trained language models so
these are figures from
a uh the citation is there at the top
from a paper
that was published this year um the
first authors out of google but it was a
big collaboration between different labs
and if you heard about google lawyers
censoring a research paper
um this was the the paper that they
tried to get the the researcher to
change
and also there was another one we can
talk about that in the q a if you're
interested
uh but the the sort of the green figure
in the
my left um is something that the authors
redacted because
they generated somebody's actual contact
information
actual you know phone number fax number
uh and they checked it and it was
correct right um
and the way that the gpt this is gpt2
this is the smaller one
and the way that these models work the
big transformer language models is you
give them a little prompt and they
generate text to fill the prompt and
there's
all sorts of applications for this
process but um one of the applications
is probing the training data set
and then over here on the other side
these like just long urls
um these are examples that uh showed up
that they could generate even though
they'd only been shown once in the
training data
so as an aside if you're sort of
familiar with transformer language
models one of the things the authors of
the papers will often argue is that
they're not doing memorization
and i think that while it is true that
not all the text that is produced is
produced due to memorization
memorization is happening and
we don't know everything that was in the
training data um the
there are some corpora that were in the
gt3 training data that lists like
nobody knows the contents of presumably
people in research group do but it was
just like
books two what books who knows um
and for you know do you know if you're
training your personal data is in the
model or not
how would you know anyway so uh this
keeps me up at night and we don't need
to
dwell on it any more than we already
have but just know that that's a thing
on the other hand rule-based methods um
so there are some real benefits to
rule-based methods um one is that
they're reliable
you you know that if you have not built
a rule to generate hate speech you're
not going to generate hate speech right
they're also easy to interpret so if
something goes wrong you're like okay so
this happened which means this will proc
when does this rule proc and you can
trace it back
much more um transparently than you can
with with most neural methods
they also don't require training data um
which
again there's a lot of training data
available for english depending on the
language that you're working in
depending on the specific domain that
you're working in
not needing training data might be the
thing that makes you use a specific
method
um and they're also very predictable
which i guess is kind of the same thing
as reliable so i don't know why i have
that as two different bullet points
but they do have drawbacks there's a
reason that we don't use completely
rule-based systems for nlp anymore
so um number one they're very narrowly
defined they can't handle
you know sort of the the wonderful
variety of human language
um i'm sure you found into this using
systems yourselves they understand a
narrow set of things and you have to be
in those things
um also for um for conversational ai in
particular
sort of a common approach is that you
would you would build out a decision
tree of all the possible ways that
people could go through a conversation
um and having worked with conversational
data uh now for quite a while
uh i could not possibly
tell you with any degree of certainty
that i could sit down and map down all
the ways a conversation can go
i think i could get most of them i think
i could get the sort of the outline
um but people would always do things
that would surprise me
has been my experience um they don't
adapt to unseen situations which you're
going to see
language is infinitely generative um and
also they're just not getting as much
press coverage
so if you're trying to like uh talk
about how great your rule-based system
is um
it's a little bit more of an uphill
battle i would say
uh so how does this play in terraza
um and what do we do so in our
assistance we have sort of a general
flow and i think is is common with uh
most
most conversational ai systems although
um also most of them are open source so
i'm guessing a little bit uh so first we
do nlu so we take
text in date text input and turn it into
numbers doing
something and for us the numbers are
usually a classification into
one of the intents that you have
predefined intents are things that your
user might want to do with your system
and you've defined them and added data
and then they're learned
um and then uh dialogue management
looks at the nlu and also the history of
the conversation
and figures out what to do next so it
might respond to the user
it might proctor you know it might
trigger some code to run it might make a
you know an api request i don't it's
whatever you want your your assistant to
do
um and it will look at all the things it
can possibly do and be like this one
this one is the most likely let's do
this in a probabilistic setting
um response generator you can use
natural language generation to generate
responses
i'm a big fan of templates which means
that the same text is always served back
and you know what it's going to be
and then that's served to the user so
talking about where we use neural
methods in
our mlu um
our sort of current state of the art
that well our
i don't want to claim that we have state
of the art and intent classification but
our current approach which is what we
recommend and uh
works pretty well for most folks is uh
called diet so this is
something that our research team
developed um and diet is a multi-task
learning algorithm um it's also
pre-trained so it's also a model
uh where we do intent so what is the
person saying and entity extraction
together
entity extraction is looking at a string
of text picking out uh the things that
refer
to particular objects that you want to
keep track of so things like
addresses names order numbers things
like that
uh yes and i'll use natural language
understanding sorry about that
um and then uh to explode that a little
bit
uh this is what's inside diet so i we
can go into more detail if you're
you're interested uh but basically the
the different uh
uh different tokens get pushed through a
whole whole set of neural networks as
you might expect they're all
stacked on top of each other um we do
use transformers so this big
transformer here in the middle we also
use conditional random fields that only
feeds into the entity not the intent
really common approach for for doing uh
entity
uh detection i'm sort of talking to the
other data scientists here if you're
like
this is a lot of words i don't
necessarily expect everyone to um
need to know all of this uh but the
upshot is
that um it's one big system yes we use
transformers
not a lot of rules in here and we do
both entity
and intent identification with a single
loss and then when we approve that over
in time
dialogue management so uh you might have
noticed not a lot of rules in there
um i could talk a little bit about the
places where we do use rules
spoiler alert it's regular expressions
uh for intents oh sorry for entities
that have a
very um specific format but mostly nlu
at this point
uh we don't use a lot of rules dialog
management
we have a couple of policies so uh the
keras policy
is i wouldn't recommend it necessarily
these days but if you
uh don't have english data and you want
to train everything from scratch based
on your own corpus and this is a good
good one to use and a policy is just a
way of deciding what you're going to say
next
and for almost everyone we recommend
ensemble of policies
so different policies and the way that
you would provide
data about what happens when in a
conversation is using stories but just
sort of like
the pattern of actual conversations that
have happened and they can be you know
things that users have said and that
you've added as training data
um so you would want a memoization
policy so
if i have seen this pattern of things
before keep following that pattern of
things
no need to to make up what you're going
to do if you have an example of what
should happen
and then one of these machine learning
based policies
so the ted policy is our our new fancy
policy
it's not that new it's you know a couple
months old at this point um
and it uses transformers which are
particularly good for this type of thing
because a transformer can pay attention
anywhere along a sequence
and if that sequence is turns and people
are referring back to different turns at
different points in time
uh rather than always referring back to
the most recent turn which is what
happens in conversations of course
you've gone to aggression you're like oh
as i was saying
um transformers are really good at
handling that uh and that is what we
we use them for
uh but we also have rule-based policies
um and we
actually over the course of developing
this open source tool and getting a lot
of pull requests and
uh you know adding things that our
corporate customers wanted and also that
the community members needed
um we found that we had a lot of
different things that were
rules basically um and as of our most
recent
major version update raza 2 we just
stuck them all in a whole set of rule
policies so that you can have
fine gain control over specific things
that your assistant does
and at this point depending on your
domain
i would almost not expect you to build
an assistant with
zero rules for initial prototyping i
would say
start with stories start with your
training data but you'll probably run
into situations where you need at least
a rule
so an example for uh for this would be
if you
are building like a fun you know
bartender
recommendation for for some sort of
alcoholic drink assistant
um the first tool is that you should ask
somebody if they're 21 and if they say
no or over 21
and if they say no immediately on the
conversation because you cannot market
alcohol to
focus under 21. um you want that to
always be the case otherwise you will be
in legal trouble
so having a rule makes a lot of sense
something that's always going to happen
in a certain way and that you can really
really count on and the way that we have
uh uh we structure rules is that um
we have sort of uh uh if
this has happened first then this should
happen next or if this has happened
first and certain conditions have
happened
this will happen next um and like i said
at this point
um it's rare for me to see uh an
assistant that's sort of ready to go in
front of users that has no rules
so uh i wanna wrap it up because it's uh
i
think it's been about half an hour um
before
we have questions um what's next for nlp
so clearly i have a researcher
background now i'm working more in the
commercial space and i would say that
even if researchers are not really
working with rules a whole bunch
although i will say
people who are not working on english
are still using a lot of rule-based
systems are still using
um cfg's context-free grammars to to
build system because they just don't
have the training data available that
english does
um both rules and neural methods have a
place in conversational ai
if you want it to work right um fully
end-to-end methods uh for
for conversational ai i would not
recommend
as a researcher and just someone who is
working in the field
um they're they're too unpredictable
training it isn't always available
um also they're just expensive uh but at
the same time pure rule-based systems
are kind of a pain in the butt if you've
ever had to work with like a
purely you know state machine dialogue
tree um
conversational system and had to update
it and make sure that the updates work
it takes some time and it can be really
hard to get your head around everything
or even honestly all the
all the dialogue trees on a single piece
of paper it's
uh when it gets complex it doesn't scale
super well
so my final point is if you were
building conversational ai
um even not with a razza um yes no
methods are great
we use them i use them they're fantastic
but they're not for everything
you need rules to to make yourself some
guard rails all right
that's all i have to say oh have i
worked with ontologies or knowledge gas
that's a great question
uh i guess i'll just go to the question
in the chat
i got a quick question rachel how often
are the um the neural models retrained
if you if you put a solution together
how often are they um
retrained is that even possible yeah oh
uh yeah absolutely so when i mentioned
um right at the beginning
that we recommend sort of a ci cd
approach we would recommend retraining
your models
you know whenever you have new data to
add so i would say probably daily
um and we also have recently
uh one subversion ago i think
we've also added incremental training
which means that you don't have to start
retraining from scratch which is
something that
was the case in the past um so you can
just update the
the model with um with your new data um
yeah but like as i would say as often as
you are pushing
pushing site updates um or when you are
noticing that things are
not starting to not work really well for
your customers
i got one more question on that so what
do you use
as feedback to target
in your retraining yeah
um so we
um so for our um
intense and entities these are labeled
um and so
the the feedback is you know for some
sort of
loss function um did you did you guess
those labeled intents correctly
uh and if you did not change what you're
doing and go back and try again and if
you did great continue doing what you're
doing so
sort of sort of back prop um and this is
um
i don't know the specific target metric
it's either accuracy or f1
um it's we're open source you can look
it up uh and then
for uh our um
uh dialogue policies um
you have the training data is
conversations right so um
if you know if this happens and this
happens and this happens then this
happens and this happens
back and forth between the assistant um
or other actions that you want to
trigger so you can
have your your assistant your target
trigger any any code that you want it to
and then send it back to the the browser
server endpoint um and it is how well
did you you do on that thing right
um did you get part way through the
conversation and the assistant tried to
do something different well
go back and go back and try again or it
keeps doing the right thing okay good
job keep doing what you're doing
so it's different things for the the
dialogue policy and the uh the nlu
rachel could you back up about two
slides
if my memory serves that's one
one more one more uh
actually it's probably it's probably
before that but uh
you you talked about in in one of your
slides that
if uh if you've
done things and you see a particular
pattern keep
doing that keep doing that pattern yeah
and in conversation and in conversations
what i was
what i was uh interested in was
preventing people from getting
into the um
how do i how do i tell you differently
that you're misunderstanding me or i
or i need to talk to a human being or
i i have some some bias against
chat bots or or whatnot
how do you build into or your customers
built into
the conversational process
and out yeah that's a great question
um so just to sort of uh i will get to
the questions in the chat i see y'all
uh so to sort of clarify what i'm saying
here um
what i what i meant is if the loss
function um is going in the direction
you want it to do
you want it to go continue to update
your i'm i'm trying to like explain my
way around macbook without actually
talking about back navigation
um so you
think there's a couple answers there so
one is uh make
by adding data and improving the
accuracy of your nlu the assistant will
be able to
understand you know the intent that the
user has
even though it's expressed in a wide
variety of different ways so that's step
one is
add more data or change the way that
your intents are written
um and that's in the early prototyping
stages that's usually the problem
um from more of a design standpoint how
do you avoid people getting like really
frustrated
and stuck in their assistant um so two
ways so one is what we call a fallback
policy so the assistant really isn't
sure what you did
what you meant and there's a bunch of
options that it could have
it could have picked um what do you do
in that situation
and uh we try to avoid the i'm sorry i
didn't understand you can you rephrase
loop um so one thing that you can do is
you can have a multi-stage fallback
policy in raza where
you can try asking somebody to rephrase
one time and if you're still like i
don't know what they're trying to do
then kick them out of the assistant and
to a human um and our
our recommendation is that um
as much as possible get people out of
the assistant
um if your assistant isn't handling what
they're gonna do well
but for the majority assistance the
right it's not going to be evenly
distributed what people want to do with
your assistant most people are going to
come to your assistant to do one or two
things and if you can do those things
really well and then if you're like
they want to do something else that's
sort of in the long tail and then kick
them out
either to like another resource or a
different assistant or a person
um if that you're seeing that like oh
we're not doing super well with like
this area of things
um so yeah it's a little bit of a
machine learning problem it's a little
bit of a design problem
and the way that you would see that it's
happening is when you're going through
and you're viewing your conversations
as part of conversation driven
development
questions from the chat did you do
uh have i worked with ontologies or
knowledge graphs
a little bit um actually it's not an old
graphics it's knowledge bases which i
know are slightly different
but tomorrow morning at 9 a.m pacific
which is noon eastern
um we have on our youtube channel a
research reading group and we're going
to be reading a paper from a shared task
on using knowledge bases which i know
are slightly different
listener plugging knowledge bases with
um
with a task-oriented dialogue
system so if that's something you're
interested in swinging by the reading
group um
yeah and dhruv says i missed the part
where you showed rules interacting with
the transformer models could you expand
on that
yeah i sort of glossed over it i didn't
have like a good visual um
but i mentioned that we recommend um we
recommend a
multi-policy approach so each of your
policies
you'll probably have a machine learning
policy you'll probably have a
memoization policy that's like
hey if you've seen this in the training
data just keep doing that thing and
you'll probably have a rule policy if
you have rules which i would say at this
point most people do
in their assistant um and what you'll do
is uh
the rule policy is almost always
extremely certain or like
no that's not that's not me i'm not
relevant here um so if
when it comes time to decide what to do
next the rule policy is like me
i know what to do next or the
memorization policies like me i know
what to do next
um because the the neural policies are
um a little bit more probabilistic
they're almost never as certain so we'll
go with with the rule
um is sort of how those work together
it's not actually in
the uh the transformer architecture
where the rules are sweet right
so let's see are these trained
independently
um are these policies trained
independently from the transformer
model so the ted policy is a transformer
model is a transformer policy and then
the memorization and the rules are
trained separately
so it's it's uh okay multiple policies
that make sense like
the sequence is what i'm trying kind of
a little bit
bumped on thank you yeah no way
and then there was another question uh
why did you use a crf after transformer
rather than using something like a by
lstm layer
so here um i'd have to go back and read
the paper
um yeah that's an interesting choice
like
where crs basically look for handcrafted
features they only go back so many steps
when you're already using something so
heavy as a transformer
probably an lst might have been a better
choice but
there might be other reasons that was
that's what pick my curiosity
yeah as i i remember the research team
tried by stms
and that they were not as
good and i don't remember the reason why
i think i think they talk about it in
the paper
um could you reference the paper i would
love to read it
yeah i'm pretty sure the the name of the
paper is just the title of this slide
um i don't think i have like the the
full citation in here
uh and bill said uh task according to
what would be the link yeah let me let
me pull up the link for that
uh and share it in here so i should also
say
uh raza is for a task or into dialogue
systems where you want to do something
you could could build a chit chat bot
with raza where it just like
says stuff when you say stuff but that
is not our our main use case because as
it turns out
um commercial
customers don't usually want to build
just like a mod that
has like fun conversations with you
usually they want to help you do
something related to their business
so nobody's doing anything like uh
senior senior care check-ins
carrying on the conversation
i would call that task oriented right
because you want to get particular
pieces of information
and understanding of particular pieces
of information and
not not necessarily but just just to hey
how it
how are things today what's see what did
you go what'd you watch
seeing any good movies that that kind of
thing just just kind of
reducing the isolation by way of
automation
i call that mental wellness or like uh
yeah
it could be it could be mental wellness
but to carry on a conversation
uh just checking it checking in with
seniors
rachel i i oh oh i was gonna say i would
look at the
clinical and lpe workshop
um so for yeah and i'm thinking for
seniors that don't have children or
whose children don't check in with them
that that this might be
an interesting alternative other than
siri or
yeah um yeah i posted i posted a quote
from vincent your
your colleague at raza i missed that
uh two for loops and if statement can
beat a neural network easily if you have
a great heuristic round
uh so
it depends i it
it was it was something that was like
wow true if you already have a leg up on
what
but you know if you have a knowledge of
the the system
the network whatever you can uh
you can actually use that
pre-knowledge that that you know
intrinsic knowledge of what's going of
what's going on
to to greatly enhance uh
the process the processing and
vincent did that in a a presentation
that i watched
and and it was good enough that i posted
it in a different
a different facebook group here here
locally
i went oh that's
that can be rather profound you don't
have to rely
just on machine learning and recurrent
neural nets and
gans etc you your nlp
you you can get a leg up on system
performance
uh if you if you know how things
are or should be processed
i would say much easier with the uh
dialogue
policies than than the nlu part for sure
but yes rules are great it can be very
very helpful
any other questions
i can ask a question if i may yes
hey my name is tolga i'm a data
scientist at glaxosmithkline
i mostly do nlp information extraction
things like that so
i'm wondering can you give a couple of
examples of the use cases and
domains specific domain that you are
deploying these conversational ai
platforms or applications and
i'm asking this because i know that most
of the nlp models
are highly dependent on the domain of
the training data
or also the tasks for example while we
are analyzing hcp transcripts we
observed that
most of the transformer models even
though
if you fine-tune it a little bit they
can still fail
so this looks pretty complicated i am
wondering how do you manage
to apply this on different domains and
what kind of use cases
you have been exposed to so far
yeah it's a good question um so i would
say the use cases that people use raw so
far
for are also a little bit uh due to
the way we do business so um mostly the
people who come to us are people who
absolutely need control over their data
um so we talked to a lot of banking
people
um we talked to a lot of um
um i'm just coming up with a lot of
examples
of clients we have where that is not
actually the main thing is that they
need control over their data
um t-mobile has um several routes of
bots in production
um a lot of companies will run them
internally
so um like to request time off or
um do other internal tasks that tend to
take up a lot of time
um grocery stores just for frequently
asked questions and people are like
what are your covet things that you're
doing um that sort of thing
um i don't remember off the top of my
head who i can talk about publicly with
names or not
um yeah it's really wide domain and our
so we definitely do like a warm start
with a pre-trained model
um but also uh it's you know
updated with uh uh and fine-tuned with
user data
um so it tends to work pretty well
again for english um for other languages
where
um we don't have quite as large but
pre-trained model um
people do need to generate a little bit
more data or have
yeah so you do get some trades
fine-tuning data from your
customer or clients yeah
we provide the framework we don't build
baths right
oh gosh okay the intent specifically
would be domain
domain oriented too right like how do
you handle intents that are not even
seen yet
um that's i'm curious about that as well
oh people provide their own intents
so the process of building a ros
assistant is
um you provide the intent you provide
the the conversations you provide the
training data for the intents and then
and then you train
i see okay okay
yeah which i realized that a lot of
other people in the space like
like if you want to use alexa you use
the tents that alexa has um and we are
being open source a little bit more
flexible
another question by the way
all right i will give you all your
screen back
as soon as i find so i think sorry i've
got several monitors and i have to find
the right one
there we go awesome thank you so much
rachel that was a great talk
cool yeah if there are no other
questions we can um
move forward to the next talk let me
just pull this up here
okay here we go
sweet cool our next presenter is
alex lev um alex is a phd student at
mit's probabilistic computing project
and a lead researcher for metaprobe
before mit
alex designed and taught a four-year
high school computer science curriculum
and he's also a native of durham so he
returns every summer to teach at
duke machine learning summer school so
alex do you want to go ahead
sure um thank you and
i'm going to try to oh um
yeah i'm getting an error for for screen
sharing
let me stop sharing okay
thank you and let me see if i can get
uh
i wonder if i share
note and then press play do you guys see
the presenter view now or the
or the actual slideshow
presenter got it um i think i can do new
share
and then just share that
how's that perfect that's it great
awesome okay um well thank you
for that introduction and and thanks uh
for having me i'm really excited to
be here talking to you and thanks rachel
for that great talk
um my name is alex lev and i'm a phd
student
at mit's probabilistic computing project
uh advised by vikash minsinka
and i'm going to be talking today about
uh
some work that i've been doing jointly
with my friend and colleague monica
agrawal her advisor david sontag
and my advisor vikash and i'm gonna
expand on this
quite a lot throughout the talk um but
the the basic idea
is that uh there's this emerging
technology called probabilistic
programming
that has really begun to take off in the
last five years or so
but kind of over the last two decades um
and probabilistic programming languages
are this whole suite of tools
um that have been developed primarily
aimed at making it easier to create
really sophisticated statistical uh
models and
you know for the purposes of ai research
but the core insights that power
probabilistic programming and the tools
themselves are
more broadly applicable than that and
the idea of this talk is to take those
insights and technology
and repurpose them to enable a style of
declarative programming that i hope to
convince you could be useful for solving
a wider range of everyday tasks and in
particular i'm going to be focusing on
the task
of data cleaning cleaning messy data so
this is a headline from
i think forbes from a couple years back
uh after a survey of data scientists had
just shown
that sort of data cleaning took a huge
percentage of
uh of data scientists times time and was
one of their least enjoyable
tasks this wasn't really the fun data
analysis
bit this was things like detecting and
correcting errors
in in a data set imputing missing values
in a data set
recognizing duplicate rows and
integrating them
and deciding on what the correct ground
truth row would be
for for that duplicate entry or this is
kind of similar to the deduplication
case but
normalizing um entries that occur sort
of
in in different references to entities
that occur
in different ways throughout the data
set so you might uh
you know to enable easier analysis you
might want every instance of the new
york times and your data set
um of employees to say
the new york times is the name of the
employer but sometimes you might have
nyt
um and data cleaning is not you know
a particularly hard task it's not where
your mind goes when you think about like
oh what we'll be able to do when we have
artificial general intelligence humans
are pretty
pretty good at it but it can take quite
a bit of thought and reasoning about
objects in the real world so
here's an example of a row for example
from a
um from a data set of apartment listings
let's say from a website like like
craigslist
and you'll see that you know the the
field
state is missing in this row and our
first thought might be well we all know
that beverly hills
is in california so we should just fill
in that beverly hills is from california
but we might also kind of be a little
bit skeptical that an apartment
in beverly hills a one-bedroom apartment
with with parking
could possibly go for 550 a month
and so we might decide that you know if
we had all the time in the world it
might make sense to do a spot check
and look elsewhere in the data set and
see does this user have other listings
you know that we can use to make sense
of this kind of strange outlier
row so we could run a query in sql
and ask uh what are this user's other
listings and we might see that the other
listings are all in st
louis and this might strike us as odd as
well because
it's a weird portfolio for a landlord to
have where they have this
one cheap apartment in beverly hills and
then a couple apartments
in st louis and that might lead us to
think
well maybe maybe there are other beverly
hills other cities called beverly hills
and um we could check that intuition by
doing another query on our data set
asking um you know what are all the
listings that are listed in beverly
hills
aggregate them by the state that they
appear in
we might see that in fact there do
appear to be other beverly hills
including
one in missouri which is where st louis
is but it's a little weird that there
are only four listings there so that
could be a fluke
so we might do another query where we
ask to see what those listings are
and they're from different users and you
know they seem realistic enough
this kind of seems to check out and the
rent per month is kind of
in the right range for the original road
that we were looking at
so we might feel comfortable if we had
to make a best guess at this point
actually filling in that the state for
this row is not california but
missouri right so this is the kind of
reasoning
that that you know best guess common
sense reasoning that involves thinking
about
real world objects like apartments and
prices and cities
and users that is necessary to do a
really thorough job of cleaning data
but people don't actually do this
thorough job of cleaning data
particularly uh
particularly often because it's it's
very time consuming
and so the question is how can we
perform this kind of reasoning at scale
and um if we think a bit about why this
kind of data cleaning is is hard
different data sets have really
heterogeneous error patterns so there's
not sort of one script that
that we can write um and as we were
talking about it often requires common
sense reasoning
and so it seems hard to write down proof
rules
uh this is kind of in line with the
weaknesses that rachel was talking about
of rule-based systems you know even in
simple cases like
let's say we just have a data set of
cities and states and we want to correct
um spelling errors in the cities right
even in these kind of simple cases
uh algorithms or sort of rule-based
algorithms that you'd think would work
quite well like replace city with the
nearest edit distance
city name in our knowledge base and then
look up the state if it's missing
can produce counter-intuitive results
right um
so it might have given us seal alabama
instead of seattle washington
or newark new york um which is a real
city but a tiny city
right instead of uh new york
new york um even though it will
sometimes get the right answer
and so writing trying to write down
rule-based scripts that are going to
work all the time
can be quite brittle um and that
motivates us to look at
maybe a different programming paradigm
so
maybe we shouldn't use imperative
programs which tell the computer exactly
what to
uh what to do or how to do like step by
step
how to do something but rather
declarative
programming paradigms which are ways of
programming the computer by saying
what you want done or what you know
rather than how to
how to perform a task now
a lot of people when they think about
declarative programming think of
logic programming languages like prolog
um
but logical rules for data cleaning
would just be
the same as the imperative heuristics
but but phrased differently
another kind of sort of declarative
programming
this is a little bit non-standard but
you could think of neural networks as a
kind of declarative programming because
in a neural network you don't say
exactly how it should compute the thing
that it's computing
you just give it a lot of input output
examples to define the task
and have it learn how to do the task but
this is hard to apply in the data
cleaning
case as well number one because we don't
actually have a ton of
examples a ton of labeled training
examples of
clean and dirty data sets for our domain
and two
um this is a paper from google machine
learning the high interest credit card
of technical debt
that sort of talks about the engineering
challenges of inc
of sort of integrating a neural network
somewhere into your pipeline
um uh for for some task
they you know it can give you gains at
the beginning but
it can also be hard to understand and
maintain as the needs
of your application change for example
if you start getting different kinds of
data in
um if a new column is added to your data
set what do you need to do do you need
to retrain the neural network do you
need to re-evaluate how well it works do
you need to do a new architecture search
so neural networks are not exactly what
we're looking at for either
now there is a third kind of declarative
programming
probabilistic programming and you could
probably tell from the
title of the talk that my answer to this
question
is is yes and the idea is that we're
going to use
ideas from probability theory to replace
heuristics
and rules with principled strategies for
reasoning about things that we don't
know
so in particular probabilistic
programming relies heavily on
bayes rule this formula for
probabilistic reasoning uh this is a
really
important formula in probability theory
and statistics uh so much so that
um at this at hp in cambridge though i'm
told that this
sign has been taken down since uh since
this photo was taken
they made a neon sign out of it and when
there's a sign it's usually because it
tells us something useful
um but but whereas this sign contains a
logical formula if you hit this sign
then you will hit that bridge
phase rule is a probabilistic formula
telling us how to reason about things
that we don't know by combining our
domain knowledge with
our observations so to take a closer
look at what it's saying there are three
letters involved a b and p
um a is going to represent the unknown
variables that we're trying to reason
about b
is going to represent our observations
which is sort of what the user actually
typed in in the data set
and p is going to represent all of our
domain knowledge that's actually making
it possible to clean the data set
so to make this more concrete um let's
consider our knowns and unknowns in
a version of the data cleaning example
that we saw before and i'll just say up
front that
in order to illustrate the way that
bayes rule plays out i'm going to use a
very simplified version of that example
with a much simpler pattern of reasoning
than the one that we
went through earlier but we'll get back
to that more complex case
uh very soon okay
so if we're trying to clean this row
what are our knowns and unknowns on the
surface it looks like we have two knowns
the city in the rent and one unknown the
state right
but the city has a typo in it um
and so we really don't want to assume
that we know the city
we want to assume that the city might be
dirty and so what we really
have is two unknowns the state and the
clean city value
uh and we know the observed city value
which might be dirty
and the rent and for this simplified
example we're going to assume that the
rent is correct
but we can look you know we could add
the rent as another unknown uh
if we wanted to that the true rent is
another unknown
then this probability distribution or
model p is going to have to encode all
of our domain knowledge about this data
set all of the assumptions that we bring
to the table that are actually allowing
us to clean the data set
so these are assumptions like more
populous cities and states
appear more often or the per bedroom
rents
in a city and state tend to be similar
across listings which is what allowed us
to do that
reasoning before about missouri versus
california
and also things like typed names of
cities
might rarely contain a typo
so we bring all of this domain knowledge
to the problem
and some of it is knowledge only about
the unknowns a
meaning which values of city and state
are more or less likely a priori not
taking into account the observations at
all
right this knowledge is going to show up
in bayes rule as p of a
mathematically it's a probability
distribution a function taking
the possible ground truth city and state
and spitting out how likely or unlikely
that city and state is based on
uh based on that probability
distribution in this case based on the
population of the city and state
the other pieces of knowledge tell us
something about how the observed
variables b
depend on the unknown variables a so the
probability function p of b
given a answers the question for a
particular fixed value of a
for a particular city and state what
values of b are more likely or less
likely
for a particular city which values of
rent are more or less likely right
and which values of type city are more
or less likely
so if we can express our domain
knowledge as a probability distribution
like this
bayes rule basically tells us how to
fill in the unknown values
so suppose that we don't know a
and we have two hypotheses um a could be
beverly hills california or beverly
hills missouri
bay's rule says you can sort of compute
a score for a by multiplying how likely
a is in the first place
by how well it explains the data b right
so in this case what we can do
is we can look at okay well consider
these two hypotheses
beverly hills california and missouri
and first consider their prior
probabilities
so in this case beverly hills california
has a higher population than beverly
hills missouri
so a priori it's more likely then
consider
their uh their likelihoods which is how
well do they explain the observed data
each of them explains the typed city
equally well because
beverly hills can be type out as beveral
hills equally
as well in both cases
but in terms of the rent the rent is
better explained
there's a higher probability of a 550
rent
in missouri than there is in california
and so in order to
sort of make a judgment here between
which one we want we're actually going
to have to weigh these conflicting
signals
and decide which product is is greater
and if we actually
were to assign numbers to these we might
be able to decide that the rent
outweighs the population difference
and we want to go with uh with missouri
here
right so this idea that cleaning dirty
data can be looked at as
inference in a in a generative model
like this or
applications of bayes rule given
probability distributions
over clean and dirty data uh was made
formal recently in a paper
uh by christopher tessa and colleagues
but it's one thing to sort of notice
this mathematically and it's another
thing to actually
code it up in a general way so
what we're going to look at today is an
approach to
creating a general purpose tool where
users are going to be able to write
scripts
encoding their domain knowledge p
and then feed in a messy data set
and then have the cleaning happen
automatically so have the inference of a
given b happen automatically
uh or in other words we want to replace
heuristic imperative scripts that do
things like
uh you know search for nearest edit
distance cities and
replace them with declarative
probabilistic ones declaring the
uncertain assumptions that a user is
bringing to a problem
we want the script to say things like
more populated cities appear more often
and if we can pull this off there's good
reason to believe that it's the right
way to think about problems like data
cleaning
because this is the kind of information
that humans communicate to each other
when we want help performing data
cleaning tasks
so this is a slide from the department
of energy that they use to train people
to clean
energy data and if you look at it it's
not a bunch of rules like if you see a
number above a certain threshold change
it in this way
instead it tells you you might see
inconsistent units of measure
we want this quantity reported in
million cubic feet but sometimes you're
going to see it at thousands of square
feet instead
so a human reading this doesn't have to
be told a procedure
just what they should assume to be true
right and then if they see
a square footage that seems a thousand
times too big
they'll they'll know what to do and i
realize i
i meant to say million cubic feet versus
therms or thousands of square feet
versus total square feet
now the challenge here is that we need
to come up with a flexible way for users
to encode their domain knowledge
and an efficient way to do cleaning
given that domain knowledge and
this is where uh probabilistic
programming is going to
just sort of come to the rescue so
remember we're trying to encode scripts
like this but using a programming
language and not english in order to
encode this sort of knowledge
now we've already seen how these
different kinds of knowledge can be
thought of as
helping to specify prior distributions
or likelihoods
and the main insight we're borrowing
from probabilistic programming is this
if we if we write a program
that randomly generates cities and
states for example
that program implicitly specifies a
distribution over cities and states
to figure out the probability of a city
and state we just look at
how likely that program is to generate
that city and state as its output
so every possible random generator of
cities and states is actually specifying
a probability distribution over cities
and states
and similarly if we write the rest of
the program to based on city and state
generate a random typed city and our
random rent
we've specified a distribution induced
by a particular city and state
over the type city and rent that means
that we can encode our assumptions
about our data set by writing fake data
generators that respect those
assumptions
right so if we want to encode that more
populated cities appear more often
we're going to randomly sample cities
according to their population
if we want to encode that rents depend
on the city we're going to randomly
generate rents based on a city
if we want to encode the city names
might contain typos we want to randomly
add typos to a city name
so putting these elements together we
have pseudo code for a fake road
generator
now in an earlier version of pclean from
a little over a year ago the idea was
that you take this pseudocode
and turn it into an actual program in a
domain specific language that we had
that we had implemented and then you
could ask pclean to clean the table
automatically
it would interpret your program as
specifying a probability distribution
and then use bayes rule to clean each
row of data
but there was a problem with this
approach that made it inapplicable to
many data cleaning tasks
and the problem is that if you look at
the uh the implementation that we have
here
you'll see that we refer to these global
constants like state populations
the list of all cities in each state the
city populations of every city
the mean rents of every city right this
is a lot of information
that we kind of have to know in order to
write this program in the first place
and that information may be very hard to
come by or it might even be the whole
purpose of our data cleaning exercise
to get a clean data set that will help
us estimate this information right
um going back to the pseudo code i mean
it's
evident even looking at this in order to
write a program that randomly samples a
city according to its population
we kind of have to already know the
populations of various cities
you kind of have to already know the
rents of different cities the average
rents of different cities
right now how do we get around this
well if you remember the example from
the beginning
it seems like a resourceful human can
still clean the data set
even without encyclopedic knowledge of
all of these statistics
right why is that well if you remember
back to our example
the hypothetical data cleaning reasoning
process we described involved querying
the rest of the data set
in order to cross check the relevant
statistics so for example the first
query here can be seen
as estimating population sizes for the
different beverly hills is
by looking at how often they show up in
the data set
so this is another way of using the
information
that that cities appear
proportionally to their populations is
to say oh well if that's the case
then i should be able to look at how
often these cities occur in the rest of
the data
in order to estimate the populations
right similarly
this second query is kind of partly
designed
to sort of cross check that the rent of
550
per month is reasonable for beverly
hills missouri
right so the question is how do we
capture this sort of resourceful
reasoning by cross-checking the rest of
the data set using bayes rule
and the key insight is about how we
decide what our knowns and unknowns are
before our knowns and unknowns were
scoped just to a single row of data
right we had two knowns and two unknowns
here and it was all about this single
row of data
and our our you can think of our domain
knowledge in this case as it is a
probability distribution over a and b
it's kind of a way of
evaluating how consistent a particular
explanation is of a of a single row
right to evaluate whether a single row
whether an explanation of a single row
or a clean value for a certain row
is good we can sort of check it against
our domain knowledge
the city field will likely be a high
population city the rent will be in line
with typical rents from the city
and the problem with this procedure is
that it required us to know
what high population cities were and
what typical rents from the city were
so the idea is that instead of
evaluating the plausibility of
individual rows in isolation which
requires us to know off the top of our
heads
these parameters we should evaluate the
plausibility of the whole data set
meaning we should assume that our
unknown variables are not just
the unknown variables of a certain row
but the unknown variables of the whole
data set
what cities even exist what are the true
names and states
of every city what is the population of
every city what is the typical rent in
every city
which apartments exist and where are
they located and with what rents
right and then which apartment does
every row refer to these are
this is like a much bigger class of
unknown variables
but and the observed variables are now
every observed cell of our data set
but given a complete explanation of the
data set our domain knowledge can tell
us
how to evaluate whether that complete
explanation makes sense
is it the case that apartments are more
common in more populated cities
well we can check that against the
complete data set is it the case that
the rent of an apartment is near the
average rent of the city it's in that
can be checked against the complete data
set
what this looks like in terms of our
sort of
fake road generator is that instead of
writing a fake road generator
the user is going to write a fake data
set generator
so a fake process for generating an
entire data set that exhibits the sort
of patterns that we expect to see
in the real data set so it might look
something like this
we're going to begin by randomly
generating a set of fake cities each
with a random name
a state that it's in an average rent and
a population
then we're going to randomly generate a
set of fake apartments
each one is going to live in a is going
to exist in some
city chosen according to the city
populations and
each one is going to have a rent which
is going to be randomly sampled but near
the city's average rent
which we already generated now for each
apartment generate a row of fake data by
adding typos to the name of the city
that it's in and outputting this
this row that has the type of city the
state and the rent
right so this is a program that
generates the entire fake data set
and if you think of it as a probability
distribution
over entire sort of clean and dirty data
sets
um it tells us how to evaluate
which configurations of the entire state
space are more or less likely
more or less likely to be generated by
this process
okay so what does this actually look
like in code we have this
this domain specific language for
declaring for defining
generative processes like this so let me
walk through line by line with what this
program is doing
so the first thing that you do when
you're writing a p clean script
is that you declare a couple classes
these classes represent the kinds of
objects that are going to underlie the
data
in our case we have cities and
apartments and the way to read this code
so far
in terms of a generative process is
we're telling p clean that the
generative process is to
generate a random number of cities and a
random number of apartments
p clean is also going to assume that
every object
should be associated with some
popularity
parameter so before we talked about
cities having populations
pclean just has built in that every uh
every object that it generates it's also
going to generate an associated
popularity or you can think of it as
there's a sort of default probability
distribution over all cities
and there's a default probability
distribution over all apartments the
next thing that we can do
is add reference slots so here we're
saying that
the apartment class has a reference slot
called location
which references a city so apartments
have
a sort of attribute called location that
is city valued
which is where the apartment is located
they're kind of like foreign keys in a
relational database
they associate objects of one class with
objects of another
from a generative process point of view
when you write down this line of code
what it's telling
p clean is that the generative process
says for each apartment
choose a city as its location based on
the city's popularity
the rest of the code inside of these
latent class definitions
is going to be attributes attribute
definitions attributes are properties of
objects
like the name of a city the average rent
of the city
the state that the city is in right
the typed name of an apartment and these
uh these attributes can depend on
other attributes uh even through
reference slots so we can say that the
typed name of an apartment
or that maybe this should say the typed
city name of the apartment
is obtained by randomly adding typos to
the name
of the location in which the apartment
is located
right and the way to understand this as
a generative process
is that for every city it's going to
generate a name and then an average rent
and then a state
where for every apartment it's going to
generate a typed name and a rent
finally we end our program with
something called an observe query
this looks like a select query from sql
if you've seen those
and the idea is that it's going to tell
us if you had a database of all the
cities and apartments
how would you pull out how would you
sort of
what select query would you write to get
the flat data set
the flat dirty data set that we're
assuming is observed
so what this is saying is the observed
data set is going to
is going to have three fields city
monthly rent and state
and the city and each one is going to
correspond to a row of our apartment
class and the way that we
create these three fields is by looking
up the typed name of the apartment
the rent of the apartment and the
location.state
of the apartment
a probabilistic script like this then
allows p clean
it licenses pclean to make certain
judgments
so if p clean sees a data set that has
a lot of entries from new york and one
apartment that says it's from new pork
but the prices are all kind of up there
in the 3 000
range you can imagine there being sort
of different hypothesized explanations
of the data
that there's a populist city called new
york with high rents and new pork is a
typo
or an alternative explanation that there
are two cities new york and newport
each with high rents but only one
apartment in the whole data set
is listed in newport or
that there's a populist city newport
with high rents and new york is a typo
that's occurred three times
and we can evaluate what the probability
of any of these explanations is
under this program and
decide that the highest probability
explanation is the first one
right because it doesn't involve uh
coincidences like you know it's much
more likely for newport to be a typo
because that requires only just having
this this typo line of code
change one letter in in this name than
it is for
um for the whole slew of things to
happen which are that the random string
that was generated
just happened to be extremely close to
new york happened to be new pork
and there was only one apartment in the
in the whole data set of apartments
that referred to newport
right so having this program
licenses certain judgments and
what i find really cool about
probabilistic programming is that by
writing different scripts
you'd express knowledge to the computer
that licenses various different kinds of
judgment
so let me just give a couple examples of
this expressiveness beyond the apartment
listings example
so in this first example suppose we're
dealing with a data set of flight
arrival times
scraped from different sources and you
want to integrate all of these together
to get sort of a
best guess ground truth arrival time
we can say that we're going to model the
data sources
as a latent class that have a name
and a reliability which is sampled from
a beta distribution which is a
distribution on the interval
0 1. so this is like a a probability of
correctness
sort of for that data source we can then
say
there are objects which are flights
sorry this code was
written to be more general than the
flight example so it's
more abstract than it needs to be there
are objects which have attributes for
example the arrival time
and then each data record has a data
source
and an object and the observed attribute
for that
for that row of data is going to be
obtained by potentially swapping
the object attribute with one of the
other possible values for that field
where the error probability is one minus
the source's reliability
and then we're going to observe the
source's name the observed attribute
uh and i you know we could have included
the flight name as another sort of
object attribute that's observed
the flight id in our flat data set
and this is going to basically license
judgments that are about well
do i trust air tracker or flightaware
based on the other inferences i've made
how often has flightaware been correct
versus how often has air tracker been
correct
um right it's going to license that kind
of reasoning about
sources of different uh reliability
strengths
it's also going to license reasoning
about you know if i have
a lot of uh rows that claim
the same thing about a particular flight
then that's probably the right answer
for that flight
and the reason it licenses that
reasoning is because this may be swap
decision is made independently for every
record
so if a lot of records have had a chance
to potentially swap away from the true
value
and uh all of them have ended up with
the same value
it's more likely that that's just the
true value than it is that that's the
uh that that's a fake value that
happened to have been chosen
independently by all of the different uh
all of the different
records a very different kind of
reasoning is licensed by this script
uh which says we have a data set of
trips that are recorded
in different countries and we're going
to model for each country
its name but also how likely it is that
a user in that country reports their
trip length
in miles instead of kilometers
then each trip uh is going to have a
country that it was taken in it's going
to have a coin flip
based on the country's miles prevalence
for whether it's going to report in
miles or not
and it's going to generate the distance
differently based on whether it's
reporting in miles or kilometers
this is going to license reasoning both
about you know it's going to allow us to
infer for each row
what units the distance is in but it's
also going to license reasoning about
that
is going to help us sort of fill in the
uh
the missing country in this row here
because we're going to be able to look
at 73 and ask
is that closer to the average trip
distance in miles or in kilometers
and if it's in miles we might choose usa
as the preferred location here
okay so going back to the apartments
example let's say we have a program
and a full dirty data set of apartment
listings
pclean can automate thousands and
thousands of these judgments in order to
infer
a database of latent objects you can
think of this as a relational database
with one class per tape or one table per
class in the program
containing all the unique cities and
apartments underlying the dirty data set
and this clean relational database can
then be used to reconstruct
a clean version of the original data set
in this example the database only has
two tables city and apartment
but in general we might have a lot more
for example in our
largest scale experiment using pclean we
applied it to this medicare data set of
2.2 million
physicians and in this case we used a
p-clean script that defined five latent
classes
so the latent database has five tables
and we can see that from the two million
words the data set he clean found
379 000 medical practices 1.1 million
physicians
around 400 medical schools over here
and around 15 000 cities
um and just to give a sense of sort of
what what cleaning looks like in a real
world example
um in this experiment p-clean changed 8
245 cells and imputed about 1.5 million
cells
and we went and manually verified these
8 000 cells that it changed and found
that
around 96 percent of them were correct
repairs
some of those were correct normalization
so a city that appeared
spelled multiple different ways that p
cleans sort of normalized to be spelled
a single way
we also looked at you know we couldn't
verify all 1.5 million of the
imputations but we verified that 90
of a random sample of 100 of them were
correct
and qualitatively the kinds of judgments
that that it made in this data set
just to give a sense of that if you look
at for example this row of data
where we're missing the degree for this
doctor kelly ryan
a human might ask what degrees are
awarded by this school typically
and we might find that do is the most
common but md
is a non-trivial share and then we might
ask well the specialty is family
medicine
what proportion of do's versus of mds
typically practice family medicine
and a higher proportion of dos than mds
practice family medicine and so we might
decide to fill it in as do and that's
what tclean does
and we were able to find on linkedin
like kelly ryan is in fact have a do
degree um a
maybe weirder example is
here are a few rows from from the
physicians data set and you'll notice
that there's an abington maryland in a
couple of them but there's also in
abingdon maryland
which seems a little weird um you might
wonder are
are there really two different cities
abington and abingdon in maryland
uh you could look at how often they each
occur in the data set and you'll
actually find abbing 10 occurs in
maryland
152 times and abbing then only occurs 42
times
but that's still not really slam dunk
evidence
to think of either of them as errors
seeming like maybe they actually do both
exist
but if you look at the data dictionary
for
the physician compare data set it tells
you that
the way they get the address the city
and state
is that they look at the practices
location the practice's reported billing
address
and they repeat that for every
affiliated professional at the practice
and it turns out that if you look at how
many distinct practice addresses are
associated with each of these
uh with each of these city spellings
abington is
only associated with one practice all
152 of these entries
are different physicians at 100 walter
ward boulevard
and this enables p clean to decide that
iving din is the correct spelling
and uh that this practice simply had a
typo
uh and and this is in fact the case
so how does you know we've looked at a
program we've looked at why in theory it
should license judgments
but how does pclean actually infer this
latent database of entries
there's a lot of research on how to do
inference in probabilistic programs
so given a generative process encoded as
a probabilistic program
how do you infer you know and given some
data that is
the output of the program how do you
infer what must have happened inside of
the program
in order to produce that output but
generic approaches
for arbitrary probabilistic programs are
often too slow
so pclean takes advantage of its kind of
restricted domain-specific inference
uh domain-specific modeling language uh
to have a specialized inference
engine for p-clean models and um here's
a uh
video of inference happening it's going
through
um what you're seeing now is on the left
the rows of the observed data set and
it's going through and sort of
as it looks at each row initializing
latent objects
of every class as as needed in a process
called sequential monte carlo
um it's going to make mistakes while it
does this but you can kind of think
intuitively about what it's doing
as you know oh i see a new row does it
fit any of the hospitals that i already
think exist if so i'm just going to
match it to that hospital
if not i'm going to if you know if it's
more probable that this is just a new
row
then i'm going to add a new row to the
hospital table
then it goes into the second phase where
it goes back and tries to fix the
mistakes that it made
and this is using um markov chain monte
carlo
uh rejuve so-called rejuvenation moves
uh
and here in order to sort of fix
a city name for example it's going to
look at what's highlighted in blue
is all of the hospitals and original
records that refer to that city
and so it's sort of this is kind of
similar to the process that we imagined
a human doing
of going to do a particular sort of sql
query to cross-check
uh to cross-check its work and you'll
see that a lot of the improvement in
accuracy
happens during this cross-checking phase
and then it does
you know you can iterate this process
over and over again but the gains
uh level off after after a bit
um and so we've we've looked at sort of
if you try to use generic probabilistic
programming techniques you don't really
get
above single digit accuracy whereas
variants of pclean's algorithm
can converge with different speeds to a
pretty high accuracy
overall it's fast enough and accurate
enough on
these benchmarks and i should say you
can't really talk about how accurate
pclean
is because it's not a fully automated
system it's about the program that you
write
so really what this table is showing is
that it's possible to write programs
um in our case all of them are sort of
under 50 lines of pclean code
that are able to clean these benchmark
data sets from the data cleaning
literature
pretty accurately with
reasonable runtime
one of the things that uh one of the
comments we've gotten about p clean
before
is that you know this seems kind of cool
but i wouldn't want to trust it
to clean my data some of the decisions
that i was talking about making in this
talk may seem pretty risky decisions to
you
uh they might seem like things that you
might not want to just just blindly add
so another cool thing is that since p
clean is embedded into this
probabilistic framework
we can actually get a sense of how
confident it is
in each of the judgments that it makes
and we can threshold uh
the changes that we make based on uh
how confident it is in that change so
what this red curve on the left is
showing is
uh for different settings of that
threshold like i want to be 90
confident or 80 confident before i make
a change for different settings of that
threshold
what recall and precision do we achieve
where recall
is what percentage of the actual errors
are actually caught
by this algorithm and fixed correctly
and precision is what percentage of the
changes that are made
are actually correct so if you want
really high precision you can set a high
threshold
at the cost of having lower recall and
by setting different thresholds you can
kind of
uh span this cur this red curve uh
trading off precision for recall and the
reason that's possible is because p
clean's confidence estimates
uh are can be relatively
uh relatively accurate so what you see
on the right is a calibration plot
that thins the cells this this data or
this table was made on
on this rents data set and it bins the
cells of that data set into different
confidence bins
and then looks at for all the cells that
p clean was 20 confident in
what percentage of them was it actually
write about
and so you can see this monotonically
increasing uh
relationship between those two
quantities on the right though it's
certainly not perfect
right the things that p clean was twenty
percent confident in it was much less
than twenty percent accurate at
but at least the things that it was
forty percent confident and it was more
than the things that it was thirty
percent confident
um zooming out a little bit
at the end um data cleaning i i think is
an exciting use case for
this probabilistic programming
technology but uh
probabilistic scripting in general i
hope can have broader applications
so um a sort of cartoonish depiction of
the main idea
is that instead of writing heuristic
imperative scripts to try to accomplish
these common sense tasks
you can write a probabilistic
declarative script that just says
that sort of encodes your uncertain
knowledge and whereas your
computer might normally say i don't
understand what you're talking about
uh if you replace your computer with a
robot who has read a probability theory
textbook
meaning the sort of machinery of a
probabilistic programming language
you can make this work out and it should
be workable
in you know or applicable to any problem
where you can sort of frame the problem
as an inference task
of uncovering unknown variables given
observed variables
and some domain knowledge so p clean
will be open sourced next month
ahead of uh our presentation of it at ai
stats
2021 it's implemented in julia um
and uh if you're interested in sort of
more general purpose probabilistic
programming languages
you can also check out gen which is um
also sort of based in our lab
once pclean is open sourced we'd love
help uh
making it scale to real to more real
world use cases
uh by building a less brittle more
extensive library of primitives for
modeling different scenarios and data
types
uh and also for implementing some
extensions to the inference algorithm
that we have in mind that will help make
it more robust
so i want to thank the members of the
probabilistic computing project and also
really thank all of you for sticking
around on a wednesday night
and i'm excited to take questions and
chat
thank you thanks mark
or alex sorry um there's a couple
questions in the chat i see here
got it cool can you pull that up or i
can go through them
uh i can pull it up yep um
and let's see so uh thanks
yeah so matt's question um how robust
are peak clean analyses to choices of
initial popularity
uh for example the prior density
function so
certainly pclean
depends on the domain knowledge that's
encoded
uh in in the pclean program um
and it is definitely possible to write
programs that yield
bad accuracy on data cleaning tasks
this particular question of popularity
is interesting because
as i mentioned the current version of
pclean
kind of assigns these popularities
automatically
that's not something that the user
controls and
uh for people who are familiar with
bayesian nonparametrics what's
happening there is that there is a
something called a pip in your process
or a two parameter chinese restaurant
process that's controlling that
and this process has two parameters that
control
sort of uh how
spread out or concentrated those
popularity distributions are
and p clean does inference per class
on those parameters as well so it tries
to learn from the
from the data itself what the right
hyper parameters are
for those for those popularity uh
for those popularities
cool so and also feel free to interrupt
with voice if
any of these are unclear answers or um
not what not what you were looking for
um
to move on to to true's question
um how can someone just getting started
pick up on what you showed here this is
useful for my case correcting ocr errors
yeah so uh
we're hoping to write some documentation
for uh
for pclean um that's one of the things
that
that is going to happen before we or you
know
uh at least a draft of that uh before we
open source it um
and one of the things we're really
curious about is once you know
we've worked with it with partners at
nonprofits to
help them clean data but it's been a
very kind of intensive process of us
talking to them and iterating on pclean
scripts
and sometimes adding new primitive
distributions to p-clean in order to
better model
the scenarios that they have and so one
of the things we're curious about is
once this is more widely available how
easy will it be for people to
um to actually use um and so
i think it's a great question and i'm
not sure what the right answer is
uh but hopefully it's something where
you know we'll have
communication on the we often are on the
julia slack
or on the github and try to figure out
what a good set of tutorial
uh material would be and how to make the
thing more usable
in terms of how scalable it is can you
use it in a real-time system
um it's a good question i mean
so far we've only done even though the
algorithm is kind of sequential and i
can certainly imagine sort of online
versions of it
that incorporate new data as it comes in
all of our experiments so far have been
batch processing
so and you know
depending on the number of rows you have
that batch processing can
can be relatively fast on the order of
seconds
or it can take up to hours for that two
million row
example that we looked at um and it also
depends
the performance that like time
performance also depends on the details
of your program
how interconnected it makes all of the
decisions uh
so i i realize a lot of my answers here
are kind of
i'm not sure but they're really
interesting questions
um for mark's
question yeah i think data linking is
one of the major potential application
areas
you say assigning multiple rows as the
same person so
remember that one of the outputs of
pclean is this latent database
of entities of deduplicated entities and
you get for every row of data that you
have
which entities it's referring to and so
you know
even though the task of data linking is
not produce a clean reconstructed data
set
you can still pull out of pclean this
inferred latent database
of attributes for each person and
reference pointers from the actual
observed rows of data
back to back to this so i'm hopeful
that data linking is uh a sort of
in-domain application for pclean
um what is the biggest technical hurdle
to getting a generic method to work
when i have a database but little domain
knowledge or coding time there is a
great impetus to have something that
just works
yeah this is uh
this is a great question if you think
about
i think it's related to the question of
how do humans
write p clean scripts right like so i'm
not an expert in hospitals
uh or medical data um and yet
after reading the data dictionary and
sort of gazing at the data for a while
was able to write a p clean script
that suggests that there should maybe be
a kind of automated
technique um for synthesizing or
at least partially automating the
construction of these p clean programs
and that's an area of research that
we're interested in other members of our
lab have
have worked on a project called bayesdb
in the past
which does automatic probabilistic
program synthesis
for uh tabular data the probabilistic
programs are not as complex as
specifically probabilistic programs
but it's possible that some of those
ideas could be used
for sort of um trying to get something
that's more like
something that just works
yeah so the question is
what makes i mean
currently
you know you plus something you just
feed your database then it kind of
graphs uh you know even even close right
um so why why is that such a hard
problem do you think because you have i
mean
yeah you have a million rows right you
can learn these distributions
um yeah well i think i think a really
interesting example is the abington
abington
example uh from the talk right where
there are more abington maryland's in
the data set than having dyn marylands
so when we talk about learning the
distribution
um like
the question is there are lots of you
know you have a million rows and what
you really need to learn
is like the perfect joint generative
model yeah
all of this data right and um it's just
even when you have really big data
there's something that uh i forget who
who was saying this i think it might
have been or maybe it's just a commonly
said thing someone must have said it
first
i don't know the attribution but that a
lot of companies that have really big
data
actually have a lot of really have many
many many
small datas right where
without the right inductive biases it's
really hard to learn
that huge joint distribution because for
all you know every row could be
following its own
new joint distribution so you have to
make certain assumptions to even make a
million rows feel like big data
you could make an assumption that every
row is independent but that and that
assumption
is generally wrong in real world data
sets
and uh i don't know if this if this is
answering
the question well but um
there just like isn't enough information
in a million rows
necessarily to learn the data
distribution unless you make assumptions
about the data distribution
uh and how it factors like
what's shared essentially what
parameters are shared
across what parts of the data set and
that's kind of what a p clean program is
encoding sure i mean i just feel like
here's one simple assumption your data
is mostly right
you know and i kind of independently
that that assumption sort of better be
correct or else you're
in trouble so i'm just going to assume
my data is 90
right and then you know most of the you
know
conditional probabilities and the
factorization that you would infer from
that
should be right but um well
i guess i think your short answer is
that it's just too hard
or i realize that's not a very appealing
answer but i think
if you think about how do i learn a
conditional probability
right like p of a given b well i can
learn a conditional
are you treating a and b as the
attributes of this data table
because if you are then you're kind of
making an assumption
that p of a given b is constant across
all of these rows
in other words these these rows are all
independent samples
from some data from some per row data
generating process
if that's the case you have a pretty
good chance of learning
this conditional distribution from the
data because the data is mostly correct
like you were saying right uh sure
but it's often the case that you don't
have
iid samples that they are tied together
by
certain shared parameters and the
structure of those shared parameters
are not the same as the parameters that
you're learning in your in your
conditional
uh your conditional probability model um
in the real world what i've seen is
there's always some data you can curate
and if you can learn from the curated
data and expand on uncurated data that
would be amazing
uh as long as your distributions don't
change between between the samples
um that's how i think i would be using
this approach
in the real world but maybe that's
that's incorrect or
correct uh alex let me know
yeah no i mean i think it's
yeah automated
you know if you look at people who do
like kind of pure machine learning
there's a lot of thought that goes into
like if you look at neural networks for
example um weight sharing
right so in encoding things like
translation invariants into the
into the structure of a convolutional
neural net
um so it's not just about getting the
right curated data set though that
definitely is a part of
how you do sort of learning but it's
also about encoding the right
inductive biases into the model
um the
yeah i like
in this data set of uh physicians
you can learn a conditional probability
that says if this is the practice
address
this is the city right if this is the
the practice addresses um uh
i wonder if i can bring up the
the figure again
right so so here right
how are you going to learn that abbing
din is correct
here right so here's the problem
abington
appears more times than abingdon in this
data set
so if you're just looking at the city
field
abington feels like a better answer
and uh if you were looking at
conditional probabilities
like you might think you might learn
that for 3491 merchants boulevard
abingdon is correct
and for 100 walter ward boulevard
abbington is correct
but that's wrong the correct process has
to do with recognizing
that what really matters here is the
distinct practice addresses
that are associated with a city that's
the right notion of frequency
in this data set because that's where
the typos would actually occur
the type like our the correct model of
typos in this data set
is that each practice address has
someone filling out a billing form
and they write down the the city wrong
on that billing form
it gets replicated across all the rows
for that practice address automatically
that's an example of structure that it's
really hard to pick up on
automatically but can easily be encoded
into this
into a p clean program i see
i mean there's a whole there's a whole
field working on extracting latent
structure from
from data like this but it's amazing
it's fascinating to find that they just
fail still apparently to really get off
the ground on solving this problem
yeah we tried running um baselines that
that were you know v8 like people are
coming up with vae
based architectures for discrete for
mixed discrete
uh continuous tabular data and
you just get kind of yeah so
the va so there are there are approaches
that just try to learn
a graphical model those approaches fail
in
in a data set like this because again
they're making this kind of like
independence given the parameters of the
graphical model assumption
which can't model things like this
abington avington phenomenon
um we were also looking at
people who are trying to take this like
deep generative modeling
approach where you don't necessarily you
don't really model
very you don't really model the causal
structure
you just have these like latent codes
and learn how to decode them into
discrete and continuous random variables
so that they
you know they're supposed to be usable
for tasks like this
but if you actually look at the
algorithms
they're making certain assumptions about
like the error models
uniform error models and things like
that uh that or independent error models
that turn out not to
hold in any of the real world data sets
that we were looking at so across all of
them
these methods perform quite poorly okay
um but of course there are methods that
work okay for for some of these
uh despite not getting the trickier
cases so the baselines that
uh that i showed it at some point um are
these like
integrated data cleaning systems that
that use other sort of learning based
approaches
uh that that can do
all right on on a lot of these uh
problems
so here like hollow clean gets 90
correct on hospital and we only get 91
correct on hospital um though other data
sets you see more of a difference
yeah thanks a lot thank you
great questions
i didn't see if there were ah can we
increase performance and precision by
cleaning and parsing it yeah so there's
definitely a lot of
um uh pre-processing stuff that you can
do
for exam to make problems amenable to
pee clean that would otherwise be hard
to apply
to pclean um so the more of that that
you're willing to do the the better
results you can engineer
like splitting email addresses uh
into the username and the
domain or things like that and then
modeling those as separate fields versus
trying to model them as one field can
make it more performant
um yeah the uh
alex the the data the data that i shared
with you a few weeks ago there's
one field for the name yep as opposed to
parse
first name and like first name last name
middle suffix
nickname that kind of stuff um
the the address fields are
are problematic because not only are
they dirty and non-uniform but
but sometimes people encode or type
both a post office box and a street
address
into what into an address
field and
the what i'm thinking of a gold standard
we have the
voter registration database and and 94
of the campaign contributions come from
within the state
individual campaign contributions come
from within the state
so i was looking to to try to match up
you
use the names and addresses
from the state registration voter
registration
but i can't i can't do that without
cleaning up
the state voter registration table which
is
huge as well as the data that we've got
coming
coming in and including parsing and
separating out oh this is a
this is a post office box so this is a
a street address and this is a first
name last name
nickname title but
right yep yeah
yeah i think i mean this is a great kind
of challenge problem to put
put pee clean to the test though i would
not make any promises that it would be
an easy
uh like a particular easy or a
particularly easy or fast
um success story right
i will get the link i'll also uh get the
links from you by way of email
you were looking for some help testing
yeah testing things out
i'll get those links and post them into
the meetup
yeah yeah please do yep that's great
thank you
and it looks like there's a last
question about how to how do i estimate
the work required to develop pclean for
a new project
in my experience uh as someone who
was very familiar with the internals of
pclean um
it often took like you know
a day to get something up and running
that was giving results that i could at
least look at with someone
but then a couple more weeks of
sustained
interaction and you know potentially
extensions to
like specific extensions to peak clean
in order to really make it
something that was like solving whatever
data cleaning need
they had
and i don't know how long it would take
you know
unless unless your use case falls into
sort of
the set that uh oh yeah so what's an
example extension
um those those model those like
functions that we were looking at like
random string
and typos and right those are all sort
of built-in distributions that have
certain capabilities
in the back end of pclean and so we
might have needed
a better string model for a particular
type of
data that the person had or something
like that um
there be a minimal support requirement
here how does it deal with sparsity
do you mean like in terms of missingness
in the data or
something else yes so let's say there
are categorical variables and some of
them are not even represented in the
data
um especially like if you're working
with ocr that's
possible two things two data points
could be very different from each other
so sorry when you say two data points
could be very different
do you mean uh so let's say we're
talking about cities right like
we have cities from one region and in in
the training set and
um completely new cities come up and
you're trying to clean up
yep yep so there's no um there's no
distinction it's a little weird there's
no
distinction right now in pclean between
a training or
test data set because everything is
batch right now
um and
so you know if if a city is only
observed once in the entire batch data
set
it's not going to be able to know uh
that it's mistyped
right unless you have a good language
model for um for the names of cities
that's able to catch the typo
uh what i mean by good language model
there is like that random string
function
if you wrote a custom random city name
function that respected
the sort of like character frequencies
of whatever language the country the
city is in
maybe that will help catch certain
errors
but in general you need to have some
example of the clean version in order to
correctly clean it
you don't need a ton of examples though
and they don't need to have occurred
in the past or like in some training set
because it's continually integrating
all the new examples thank you
thanks thanks for the great questions
and it's also great to be at a durham
event even
virtually
awesome thanks alex and thanks everyone
for asking questions
um yeah let me share my screen again and
we can move on to
lightning talks
thanks thanks okay
cool so yeah now it's time for lightning
talk so if anyone has anything to share
um five to ten minutes or less for any
data science topic or any format
um please you know request in the chat i
think
mark hutchinson you wanted to kick
things off
sure let me see if i can share my screen
oh okay let me try again a little
little quick with the share my screen
okay can you
can you see my my slide
that looks good okay uh oh it's just
about it's eight o'clock hey
it's easy to keep track of um hello
everybody i'm one of the organizers
mark hutchinson um welcome thank you
for uh joining us uh this
third uh the second one of 20 the second
meeting of 2021
hope everybody is safe um
thanks alex thanks rachel for uh
for doing the presentations today um
i want to make an announcement which is
we've
we've brought on brought on board two
people uh
into the organizing uh committee
um our host tonight our host tonight and
going forward arthi
janaki ramen i got it yeah
got it and drew sockley um
uh i'm i i
put out a call because we we had a
alice alice was uh
unable to continue as a host and
organizer
and it was just me and gene and i
thought
well we need some more people
one of the things in addition to host in
addition to hosting
or organizing one of the things that we
do
is recruit for instance uh
alex i saw give a presentation
at closure conju in fact i wasn't there
i saw
a video of alex doing his presentation
uh it was a presentation on jen a couple
years ago
so i went oh that's neat and
knew that that that that library that
library
and uh represented a way of
of probabilistic an implementation of
probabilistic programming
and thought that that would be very
valuable for us
so i started recruiting him and finally
his school his schoolwork
has allowed him to give the presentation
here why am i showing you this slide
because we are operating in a vacuum
unless you help us
by telling us what you would what is of
interest to you what topics of interest
are you
you don't have to give a presentation
but
what what types of data centric
presentations
would be of interest to you and
uh if you know of somebody
put them in touch with us or put us in
touch with them
all of us me drew gene and arthy
you can contact through meetup and
um there where we're on the organizer
list if you send
if you send a message to uh the
organizer team
we should all get a copy of it and we
will work with you
in trying to get a fine find a presenter
or
get in touch with and schedule the
presenter that you would like to
hear or see uh
this is our group this this is the group
not of the organizers but of all of the
members of pi
data triangle and as such
we would like to work together with
all of the members we the organizer team
would like to work with
everybody to to present things that are
relevant to you
are useful to you or just of interest
to you and that's
that's what i would like to to to say
and
i'm going to stop sharing and i did it
all in three minutes
hey i got an well in under time
any questions
hello
i guess there are no questions all said
mark
okay hey
hey jim did you uh still want to talk to
the group
jim french
yeah no i ended up not i was on a call
for two hours so
i wasn't prepared to i'll try it another
time okay
cool cool thanks
cool um yeah anyone else want to give a
lightning talk today
next time then
next time a technical talk from me
great okay well thanks everyone for
coming to the march pie data conference
um gene or mark do you want to have any
thoughts everybody have a good night
thanks for um sticking another zoom into
your busy schedule for the day
at the end of the day thanks
bye-bye bye bye